eine weitere tragödie vor der insel
lampedusa
der dokumentarfilm vor kamera zeigt was
die nachrichten nicht zeigen etwas fast
bizarr poetisches einen anderen blick
auf die realität und plötzlich sehen die
überlebenden aus wie die heiligen aus
dem morgenland
dieser film ist politisch weil die frage
eine politische ist paradoxerweise gibt
es auf der insel kein kontakt zwischen
den einheimischen und migranten
die leute denken auf lampedusa seien
alles miteinander verwoben
doch so ist es da nicht da ist eine
strenge trennung ein jahr lang lebte der
regisseur auf lampedusa
wie lebt es sich auf der insel vor der
das sterben mittlerweile fast alltäglich
scheint
und werden
volker male ist der erste dokumentarfilm
der den goldenen bären der berlinale
erhielt ich wäre ein schrecklicher
drehbuchautor ich bin nicht in der lage
auch nur eine zeile zu finden
die realität muss zu mir sprechen wenn
ich einen zugriff auf den stoff haben
ich möchte die strukturen geschichte
finden wenn ich die schon wisst
bräuchten
hier laufen nachrichten bilder aus aller
welt ein
die realität ist das was ist und von ihr
gibt es verdammt viele bilder je mehr
man sieht desto mehr stumpft man ein
dauerfeuer der kommunikation wie will
man da noch eigene schlüsse ziehen
gianfranco rosi wollte dem etwas
entgegensetzen
langsam sein wo das fernsehen schnell
ist mehrdeutige bilder und nachrichten
bilder schnelle schlüsse versprechen was
heißt das eigentlich so und so viele
flüchtlinge sind auf lampedusa gelandet
nur weil man etwas erlebt hat liegt es
nicht hinter einem
sie haben viel hinter sich jeder hat
seine geschichte
und nein die flüchtlinge sind nicht
einfach nur zahlen ihre geschichten
gehen uns alle an
wir erleben gerade eine der größten
tragödien seit dem holocaust
wir reden hier von 20-30 40.000 menschen
die mehr sterben am versuch zu fliehen
zum ersten mal sehen wir live bei sowas
zu diese bilder des todes ununterbrochen
leute starben hier und da dieses klingt
dieses kleine kehrt die tun nichts
dagegen also sind wir verantwortlich für
diesen neuen holocaust
die bilder des vergangenen holocausts an
der erst später aber jetzt sehen wir die
lehrer jeden tag tun nichts die
verantwortung der politik ist gewaltig
alltägliches grauen direkt vor der
eigenen haustür programm erzählt von
einem europäischen dilemma was tun sich
einfach daran gewöhnen wie soll das
gehen